los habitantes de bogotá vuelven a salir
a las calles a hacer deporte gracias a
la reapertura de la ciclovía que estuvo
cerrada durante 5 meses todos los
domingos y festivos- bogotá pone a
disposición 127 kilómetros de esos
vídeos para que la gente tenga la
oportunidad de hacer ejercicio al aire
libre en este día de reapertura se vio
mucha gente pues a las 7 de la mañana
que es la hora inicial de la ciclovía ya
varias de las calles estaban
completamente llenas es una de las
oportunidades que hace que las personas
salgan se distraigan y que de cierta
manera como que no lo olvidemos pero sí
tengamos precaución frente pues a la
pandemia pues es realmente una buena
iniciativa por parte de la ciudad que
creo que la evidencia hoy por hoy
muestra que este tipo de actividades al
aire libre pues tiene muchísimo bajo
riesgo que otro tipo de actividades
entonces era importante que la gente
pudiera salir pudiera moverse que
pudiera tener un espacio diferente para
que para salud mental como también para
mejorar el sistema inmune
además de esto todos los 65 parques de
la ciudad los senderos ecológicos y los
gimnasios al aire libre también abrirán
de nuevo sus servicios a todos los
ciudadanos hace unos días de alcaldesa
de bogotá claudia lópez puso fin a todas
las cuarentenas obligatorias que se
estaban organizando en varios sectores
de la ciudad y le dijo a todos los
ciudadanos que a partir de ahora el
cuidado desde cada uno así que se
mantendrán las medidas como el uso
obligatorio de mascarilla también el
distanciamiento social y el buen lavado
de manos